it's been a day of remembrance here in
germany to pay tribute to the almost 80
000 people who have died of covert 19
since the pandemic hit the country their
commemorative service was led by german
president frank walter steinmeier in
central berlin
it was he said a chance to say goodbye
in dignity
to those lost to covet 19. many of whom
died alone
and without their families because of
pandemic restrictions
president steinmeier was joined by
chancellor angela mecco and other
political leaders
and by family members of some of those
who died from the coronavirus
they begged their fellow germans to
continue to do all they can to keep
themselves healthy
and to keep others healthy by following
pandemic restrictions
in his theology president steinmeier
spoke of the loss
of the victims
today we're focusing not on numbers and
statistics
but on the people that we've lost women
and men
from all regions of our country the very
elderly
but also people of all ages we call to
mind their names
faces and stories
for all their differences and the
different ways in which they lived
they're all missed by their families and
friends
by their neighbors and their colleagues
by our society
and with me in the studio is our
political correspondent hans brandt
now hands it was definitely
very emotional um what where can we
start
how touching was it to hear from family
members of
those who had lost loved ones well yes
that was i think the point of the
ceremony although the president
obviously spoke
a eulogy it was meant to be a service or
a commemoration
event for the victims and their families
and they were from a very wide spectrum
obviously that was the way that they
were chosen also the way that they were
picked there was
a woman who lost her disabled young
daughter to covet 19
there was the wife of a doctor who ran a
hospital and in his own hospital
presumably
caught the virus and then died
there was also the daughter of a turkish
immigrant
who made his family life here in uh
in germany and the daughter very young
daughter of a man
who was very young when he died but did
not die of covert 19 he died of leukemia
of cancer of the blood
but also died basically on his own
alone because of the restrictions and
finally there was
the son of a woman who was in a care
home because she was
suffering from dementia and she too was
in a sense left alone because her family
was not able
to see her during that time is there a
reason
for the timing of this service why now
there is no exact reason to there has
been some debate about this in fact some
people have said the commemoration
should have happened a lot earlier
other countries have had similar events
before
some people say we should be
commemorating victims continuously
because people continue to die and we
should not ignore that
the president himself has said it's now
been a year or just over a year since
the pandemic struck
we cannot wait for the pandemic to end
to do this commemoration because we
don't know when it will end
and so he's saying it's a moment to
stand back
and to in a sense uh commemorate but
also to gather our strength
for the new continuing infections the
continuing the third wave as we're
talking about it at the moment
of this pandemic now uh sticking to that
uh looking ahead germany as you rightly
said it's in a grip of a third wave with
record new infections in recent days
what is the government proposing to do
there's been a lot of dispute about what
is the right way to go
and this dispute has been in fact going
on for months mainly it's
the central government of angela merkel
the chancellor on the one hand
and on the other side the 16 federal
states and their leaders
who in fact have um the the power to
decide what happens in their regions
and while angela merkel has always been
for stricter measures
the regional leaders have resisted that
and that continues to this day at the
moment
there are discussions about imposing a
central government lockdown
a a new law is likely to be passed for
that
in this coming week but there's still
resistance from the regions
so it's not quite clear to what extent
angela merkel is able
to push through what she really would
like to do a hard lockdown
i guess only time will tell dwc's
political correspondent
hans brandt thank you
detlev jacobs keeps memories of his
mother renate alive
in this photo album
my mother was a person who liked to be
around others who like to be with
friends
who like to socialize if she hadn't
caught the virus
the nearly 80 year old would probably
still be alive
like helga kukkot who was also a victim
of the pandemic
my mother was an exceptionally strong
person who put a lot of energy into the
family
and also kept the family together
she was the heart and soul of the family
for everyone in it
the 93 year old was fighting fit before
she was transferred to this clinic
after catching the virus in the care
facility where she lived
but her son doesn't blame anyone for her
death
we had to spend those beautiful summer
months
where you had the feeling that life
could go back to normal
so i can't blame anyone
looking back knowing what i do today
they could perhaps have had stricter
measures in place
the months before his mother renatus
death were particularly difficult for
deadlove jacobs
she was in a retirement home because she
suffered from dementia
and due to a strict lockdown in the
spring no one was allowed to see her for
months
it was difficult because my mother
couldn't be reached by telephone
due to her dementia she often didn't
respond to phone calls
so those three months were very hard for
us relatives
in the summer deadlift jacobs was
finally able to see his mother again
but then she was infected with the virus
and had to be quarantined
when her situation worsened and her
children desperately wanted to visit her
it was too late during the pandemic many
people like hegel caught passed away in
extremely lonely
circumstances her kakokot's son could
not be with her when she died
in my case it wasn't possible because i
have a sick family member at home whom i
have to protect
i was very concerned that i might bring
the virus home with me
renata jacobs was a florist and always
very close to nature
she wanted to be buried in the forest
thankfully that left jacobs was able to
grant his mother
her last wish now to some
other developments in the pandemic
india recorded more than 230 000 new
cases on saturday
that's more than three times the daily
case number in the u.s
the world's worst hit nation
pope francis has given his first
in-person sunday blessing
in the vatican after weeks of lockdown
italy is set to begin easing
restrictions later this month
israelis no longer have to wear face
masks outdoors
and schools have fully reopened in the
latest steps towards normal life
after a mass vaccination campaign